Prop 8 section 8 are we ready
[Applause]
guy you look like a Jeff Ross beanbag
chair tomorrow you're so hot but you're
so ghetto and uneducated I never know
whether I should you or try to
teach you Shakespeare through hip-hop
God you do fat to be trying to ride dick
my nigga this nigga so gay he only came
out the closet so his daddy would spank
them
tomorrow at least my father waited for
me to come out of the closet to reject
me
[Applause]
tomorrow Jamar grew up poor but his mom
did the best with what she had
unfortunately what she had was crack
cocaine she is very very lucky that you
cannot pay for an abortion with an EBT
card a malignant tumor that's topical
it's a sad shape you got all that blood
and can't donate none of you thank you
Jim Marrs never met his dad which makes
a lot of sense women rarely keep in
touch with the guy who paid them too
bologna sandwiches to behind a
dumpster
I'm all for presentation and this when
they came out with the fans I'm like
how's he gonna top that and then he
brought his neighbor
[Applause]
thank you what did this great guy but I
gotta give it to Jabbar in his
neighborhood I thought when you first
came out it was over I didn't realize he
was going up against Jamar I seen Jamal
before he's very very risky and I was
actually scared and then the comebacks
was amazing I gotta go a guy it's the
first time for a gay person all right
D'Elia
you both seemed very confident I think
personally uh it's tough but I gotta go
with Jamar I mean that beanbag
chair joke as always guy your jokes are
oh so so well written to Shakespeare
through hip hop joke so funny that was a
good one yeah you're really becoming
just a great comic and a super funny guy
however I think we all know tonight was
Tamar's night you killed her father
[Applause]
yeah
it's fantastic
I was afraid I'm not gonna lie Oh
an old straight guy judging panel
surprise surprise
yeah I hear a stronger day give me kiss
alright man my mama watching his mom
house ready guy
[Applause]